[Music]
imagine two similar women who each have
unwanted pregnancies they both go to
abortion clinics
one has a pregnancy that's just days
before the clinic's gestational limit
and the other is just days past the
limit
so one of them receives an abortion and
the other is turned away
their different life trajectories after
that might not tell you a lot on their
own
but if you were to track this scenario
for hundreds of women you could gather a
lot of data on what life looks like
after women are denied an abortion
this was the concept for a huge
naturalized experiment in the u.s that
tracked this for the first time
for five years every six months
researchers called the women to see how
their lives had progressed
and one of the things their research
uncovered was the financial impact of
forced parenthood
what they heard from these calls reveals
the high economic cost of an abortion
ban and exactly who is made to bear that
cost
hello
there's no way that you don't have a
child and love and want that child and i
very much feel that way about my son but
that isn't that isn't how we began i
felt like i was drowning and had zero
control over my life and having an
abortion felt like reaching out for air
the voices you hear in this video
weren't part of the study but their
stories overlap with some of its
findings i was six months along and so
at that point i had to carry to term
there wasn't a choice of am i going to
give birth or not i'd actually made that
decision twice in life for me they both
felt pretty easy right away
roughly 60 of women in the study and
abortion seekers in the u.s are already
parents
abortion seekers in the study and more
broadly are much more likely to be a
person of color when compared to the
general population
and are almost four times as likely to
live in poverty
and that can be about who has access to
contraception who has had
great sex ed classes who can negotiate
contraceptive use with a partner
and it's also
about who can accommodate a surprise
pregnancy
diana green foster is a demographer who
led the study which she calls the
turnaway study
among all women in the study there are
three groups we'll focus on one group
was women who got an abortion in the
first 13 weeks of pregnancy the first
trimester
this stage of pregnancy is when about 90
of abortions in the us happen in the
general population
but for the study it was
underrepresented and used as a control
group for this group women who got
abortions within two weeks of an
abortion clinic's gestational limit
which averaged at the 20-week mark
this later abortion group is a less
common abortion experience in the u.s
but for the purposes of the study it was
overrepresented
in order to compare to this third group
women who just barely missed the
gestational limit and were denied an
abortion
this last group is called the turnaway
group
the turnaway study hinges on comparing
the outcomes of these two groups
but comparing the two groups of women
who sought later term abortions to the
first trimester group can tell us
something too 40 of the first trimester
group were living under the poverty line
but 57 of the later term abortion group
were
lack of money slows people down and
prevents them from moving as quickly to
getting an abortion wealthy women have
unwanted pregnancies they are more
likely to get their abortion and that's
because they can afford to do it they
can travel they can pay for the
procedure they can get time off work
in fact when women in the study were
surveyed about their motivations for
wanting an abortion not financially
prepared was the most common response
what was going on in your life
when you had an unplanned pregnancy
we were barely able to scrape by at that
point and there was just not enough
money the financial situation was like a
really big deciding factor for me i just
graduated from undergrad i was doing an
unpaid
fellowship we live in the bay area you
definitely need a dual income household
to be able to live well so we were not
okay financially because of my uh
documentation process i couldn't legally
work i was just starting my professional
career when i found out i was pregnant i
was three months into my first real job
out of college
one thing researchers asked the study
participants over the years was whether
the relationship that led to the
pregnancy lasted
this was to try to get an idea of
whether these women had support
at the time of the abortion clinic visit
80 of the study participants said they
were still in this relationship
by the second year that number fell to
60
and by the fifth year only about 27 of
them were
regardless of whether women in the study
received or were denied an abortion the
likelihood of the relationship working
out was low
he gets to go off and live his life and
forget that he's a father and while my
entire life is about being a mother and
caretaking for this person it is already
like a lot to
go through unexpectedly and it's a lot
to do it on my own
the high likelihood of that relationship
ending makes sense given that another
common reason for wanting an abortion
was for partner-related reasons
i don't know that it would have been a a
healthy thing
for ourselves or a child to have to
endure those types of disagreements that
type of conflict that type of disconnect
trying to measure other types of support
researchers found that five years on
women denied abortions were more likely
to be living alone with their children
than women who received abortions and
had other children
it didn't look like they were getting a
lot of support from their partners or
their immediate family
we looked at child support payments on
average it was only about
twenty dollars a month twenty dollars in
child support that's extremely low
yeah and this is including a lot of
people reporting getting zero dollars of
child support and then a few people
reporting getting normal amounts of
child support
and finally the researchers gathered
financial data for these two groups to
figure out what becoming apparent
without much support looks like
we linked the participants in the
turnaway study to 10 years of credit
reporting agency data and this went back
before their pregnancies
researchers looked at financial distress
indicators like debt or evictions in the
two groups and before the turnaway group
gave birth the two groups were on
similar economic trajectories
but after the turnaway group gave birth
the two groups diverged and the level of
financial distress for the women denied
an abortion spiked
we saw this big spike in financial
problems among the turnaway group nearly
80 higher
amounts of uh debt that was 30 days or
more past due 78 increase in things like
bankruptcies or or liens or evictions
where you're ordered to pay the landlord
some amount of money and we saw a big
spike in those so some people might look
at this research and say
you're going to be more financially
strained if you have a child because
your life is just going to be more
expensive so why is it important to look
at this in relation to an abortion
denial
one thing we did
to
investigate this question was we looked
in the near limit group so some of the
women who initially obtained an abortion
later went on and had a pregnancy that
resulted in a child and and they gave
birth
after the birth of their children the
financial distress indicators for these
two groups looks like this
which shows the more severe financial
penalties for women having children when
parenting is wanted versus after an
abortion denial
the women in this study were seeking
abortions because they they knew that
this was a bad time for them they knew
this was a time where it would be
potentially really really costly and
really damaging to them and their
economic circumstances
and not just their own
55 percent of the children of the women
who were able to get an abortion were
living in poverty
that number rose to 72 percent for the
children of the women who were denied
which is relevant to another common
reason study participants gave for
wanting an abortion
the need to focus on other children
one of your fears when you were deciding
whether or not to have an abortion
was that you wouldn't be able to afford
the child care and i'm wondering how
much of those fears were realized for
you oh 100 of those fears were realized
for me i don't have child care now
there's still no way to afford child
care on my salary
something the turnaway study shows is
that these reasons turned into accurate
predictions of what the women would
struggle with after an abortion denial
women understand the consequences of
unwanted pregnancy and when they're
trying to decide whether to have an
abortion or have a baby they understand
completely what the outcomes will be
was able to go to law school and
complete the degree that i've been
saying i wanted to do since i was eight
years old
my life outside of being a mother has
just been
exponentially harder and almost
impossible and there was mourning for
the life that i imagined there was just
no way i would have the time or money
to do those things
like going to grad school or moving away
from family
i was able to fight the deportation case
and i
have a career i was able to get out of a
marriage that just wasn't working
because i didn't have to think about how
it impacted somebody else i
get to
define my life the way that i want to
without having to factor in a family
if somebody tells you they're not ready
to carry a pregnancy to term they're not
believe them
[Music]
[Music]
you